and hey everybody what's going on
bleh here welcome to another Monday
melee today we're gonna be doing
something we've done before but we
really liked it was really fun we're
gonna play battlefield hardline with you
folks that's right so we're gonna play a
quick one player a battlefield hardline
but what I want everybody to do is if
you haven't added me already add Blair
as your friend on Xbox one and if you
got battlefield hardline fire it up and
we're gonna play we're gonna play today
we're playing with fans it's gonna be
super exciting with me today are JD
diamond hey from Kona Coast barosky's in
the chatroom as always lovely chatroom
moderator and she loves using the
banhammer so don't f with her and other
ones a Tuesday snow malli
over there in the corner and then the
creeper today it's Chris Waller say hey
Oh creeper the corner ah
so let's get going you ready are you
have you ever played this game no never
fantastic it's gonna go very well I love
it I love it hey Terra meets this how's
it going air fgh oh yeah starts alright
also I should say tune in later today on
Monday melee we're gonna have a sneak
preview of tonight's newest clueless
gamer episode which is gonna be on the
show t vs 11:10 central so make sure you
stick around for that it's gonna be very
exciting our a wire rich I'm not at e3
I'll be there later this week on
Thursday I think I'm going to e3 yes I
did go to t I did get to go to the
Bethesda the Bethesda showcase last
night Dolby theater it was really really
fun very excited for the new Fallout
very excited I saw there's this game
called Dishonored which seems cool
that's right exactly exactly very very
exciting yes doctor that's JD fridge
oculus is great
no rush escape Conan's not going to e3
he's got to do a show but I hope you
there sorry is that my friend yeah dude
get on the bite on this oh no I think
you guys press press press in on the
left stick to run I think you want to
chase you want to just chase chase did
it freeze yeah the worst it was my fault
I just shot at the garage door dude
should we start up something else and
maybe that'll kick started back in to
sorry everyone
worst person ever and here we go we're
starting over
yeah next boat hashtag anyway I'm very
excited for we're excited for the new
pathetic games those look pretty pretty
exciting James the clueless gamer game
tonight will be playing which coders
already tweeted out about is the new
halo halo 5 Guardians that's right
and we got to do something very very
special with halo 5 guardians so thank
you to 343 and the Microsoft team for
for helping us put all that together
it's very very excited I think you guys
are gonna be hopefully happy I think it
turned out pretty funny it took a long
time to put together it's an awesome we
shot for like three hours
it would pretty crazy there's a lot of
really cool stuff in the new Halo maybe
we should just play multiplayer there's
a lot of cool stuff in the new Halo that
I'm very excited about all right let's
try this we're gonna try to play what's
that
multiplayer we're gonna try to do
multiplayer with you guys
right now it says no friends playing and
no servers
that's right no friends love halo so
sure I'd join a squad is that what we
should do here rush escape rush escape
no they never fixed the urinal they
never put a thing there ever will be
playing with them we're going to if they
would get online if people guys get
online alright so you're forcing you're
forcing rj to play single-player right
now i just want you guys to know that
gonna be bad
it's you already rather murder me yes Oh
what I said I'll start I'll start and
then when I die
alright fine you'll get out of the
garage
Laura white your voice got so much
sexier bleh that's right I terrible
allergies this weekend it's my voice is
incredibly sexy right now
shady fridge do you still have your
weather app RJ yes I do
all seven Tuscany hashtag no friends
exactly got it great alright let's play
what I like about this game two is tell
me what it's about basically we're just
two cops trying to clean up the streets
man silver happens you pick quick match
let's see how connected the internet
like last week we can't both play right
now
they did that
duska hoody that's you
taking him down
yeah
hardline voter live more like oh so left
trigger aims right trigger fires ex
reloads
you have to aim shoot I mean it helps
when you push in the left stick oh yeah
I was I supposed to run upstairs by the
way I'm just running upstairs that a bad
idea for sure what's happening on there
I don't know when the EA conferences
yo-yo laptop lady tizzy
she isn't named that's bad I would have
changed my name oh that's a good idea
is that URL taken there's a big washing
machines hey I should sneak by these
guys or what what are we doing no man
we're cops Jesus we don't have a guest
today but we do have a preview of closed
exam so that should be enough for you
yeah exactly taking him down
what taking them down man I'm just doing
I'm doing my public service what happens
if you kill them if you shoot them yeah
right in the groin that's right so they
call me old dick shot Blair oh right in
the hand don't have with me dude over
where
where am I at where am I at right in the
dick right in the dick don't ever don't
ever get him in the Weiner
Oh hit that dick a dick shot hashtag
diksha pow pow don't ever have with me
boy sorry I'm really amped up for Monday
shoot a bunch of dicks man you know
dicks on dick son ticks way to warrior
we have hashtag Weiner worry dude
tactical gear give it to me I'll take it
off every something good in here
gadget one what's that a Taser oh oh
yeah yes please
gadget to no gadget what is this zipline
grappling hook armored insert ziplines
well well well someone's dick is about
to get perforated who wants a perforated
wiener
hashtag Weiner warrior we don't worry no
wait a second hurts hurts I'm Erin Erin
dick I don't like that hashtag no no
please wiener warriors that is the
preferred hashtag for today can you
shoot down he's just chillin he's just
sleeping
oh come on what this gun can tase him
he's down oh I'm not gonna tase him when
he's down don't tase me bro all right
let's go let's go where we going let's
go no dude we're just trying to fight
crime man rush to skate stop using the
hashtag Aaron dick please Weiner
warriors somebody such a good one it's
illiterate guard your dicks officer
blaze yeah exactly exactly
armor those dicks gentlemen wear a cup
I'm powerless against ladieswear pull up
there cuz they don't have dick so I
can't shoot him in the dick what
happened he just passed out what if this
is all about stealing laundry oh no this
is my partner I think don't trust me as
a vest on
shoot him she's like stop shooting
everyone's dick
he's face the other way how am I gonna
shoot him in a dick get some laps in
dude what there's another pool oh whoa
I'm getting shot at he's crouched but I
think I hit him in the dick
oh that's it I'll take a headshot pulls
on foam either kind thank you see you
guy over here somewhere no RJ the map is
your friend ooh
get them right yeah right signature
signature move feeling it would you
relax this way oh I got a special
surprise for someone come around the
corner
am I supposed to be chasing somebody
this thing is a great dick plaster all
right there we go
we've already we've ruined the chat
early today I think yeah we've destroyed
the chat huh I just killed everybody I
don't I'm not sure that's what does cops
supposed to be doing here all right
where am I going
you gonna check out you know what I just
do a passive checkout I just leave and
they eventually find ever seen that show
or movie or whatever it is don't care
very the chat better less dick talk to
me dick jokes I know Toscanini I know
sorry so the whole point of this of us
playing this today is to play with you
guys so do you guys have battlefield
hardline please jump on xbox one and can
I go in here jump on Xbox one so we can
all play each other I want to play with
fans today I don't want to play with
myself
hahaha I made that joke on purpose by
the way anyone know where I was supposed
to be going my gals over here somewhere
Nonie
can't go this way oh you know what oh I
think it's on the first floor maybe I
might be underneath here water
I'm getting my slacks all wet I bet this
guy wears slacks oh yeah I feel like
it's like yeah we shot help me out wait
here I supposed to climb up
III de0 coverage is officially begun III
dig I've really need three for everyone
I feel it look you see that where that
person is so am I supposed to get up
here it's not the idea can you jump on
these flowers yeah
get up here what about that grappling no
I don't I don't think I happy crap wait
wait what about Vista there I think I
wasn't supposed to come down in the
courtyard right other way in the middle
okay help in laptop QT here other stairs
in the pool so you see I don't see any
stairs checking the middle oh hey
battlefield hardline no be great is like
an arrow somewhere oh this way oh maybe
this way
careful sleepwalker yes look floor with
blood oh here this way it's gotta go
yeah right
exit I'm sorry you come Conoco no
lobby's this way oh and there's deeds
and now you tell me that I've already
found it thanks for nothing get upstairs
I was just upstairs
stop yeah dude it they have respect for
the law you should have a little shred
for the law whoo but what happens if you
shoot them Dave lose no they get killed
oh because I've shot them
the question is can I like arrest all
these guys or what you and your dick are
coming with me I do now that I bought a
bunch of funny t-shirts
today's shirt is I am the bathroom I'm a
horrible garbage person and my to do got
it got it perfect time to do all right
today will be a more laid-back
Spyder perfect well thank you for
joining us thank you exactly what kind
of heart is this beautiful our be open
yes hello youtubers I got my scanner out
he's got running up the stairs Oh
hope you're wearing Armour headed
upstairs
[Music]
what games hey chat what game what game
is everyone excited for for next yearfor
III what games you excited to see like I
said last night I went to the Bethesda
event it's awesome fallout 4 looks
amazing as does like Dishonored looks
like a pretty fun game oh jesus is
insane I'm a Mario star hello Poland
hello half-life 3 half-life 3 mercs
cough even and now it's half-life 3 have
a Tomb Raider looks amazing
doom looked amazing - I agree choco doom
is unbelievable what did they yeah they
just finally why did they do that the
beginning you have to like put the disc
in and then download a digital a digital
patch
here you go alright so you gotta kill
let's kill all those guys downstairs
yeah
so so be is your friend beat crouches i
can't wait to see how RJ gets killed so
quickly be crouches left trigger aims
right trigger shoots police you can also
just tell people I spanked myself I'm
looking forward to Hello Kitty Island
Adventure really he'll do it that'll do
it
I have not played any persona game Laura
why trick for Sona 5 what sports persona
how do I feel
Russia skate why is it on Mondays 20
sounds better here's why we changed it
from twitch 20 a tomato monday melee
because on Wednesday we taped two shows
now so now it's too hard to get Conan in
ever so I wanted
I know Conan Cota comes in every once in
a while but we would have no chance of
getting him if we did it Wednesdays so
Mondays we switched it so sometimes he
comes in sometimes he doesn't but that
was the main reason I'm waiting for Co
to the game to go back sorry it's
alright I didn't know I spank myself
yeah that's your whole name what's that
ray 2255 said yes we play Mortal Kombat
actually we did a whole clueless gamer
with Mortal Kombat X with two guys who
play football over in the Super Bowl
Beth will hit you with a link it was
super fun
that's right I'm Craig husky and I'll in
squash your grief gun thanks King Hawks
I love your name by the way King Hawks
great names guns why there we go
hell yeah our JRPGs you should try them
what's a JRPG I don't know that is pika
code it do the beta on Xbox one I will
yes Bart that's correct
mind meld that's right
it's like anyone who I love anyway Perry
their chat message was please stop
poison gas
Oh Japanese RPG got it got it whoa hey
Tuscany we're playing for another hour
so you've got another hour until 625
thank you for checking us out
Japanese don't let her take die please
react to chug another special episode of
RG and play I don't know when are we
getting another special episode I don't
want a player but I don't know if that's
gonna be possible you know we could just
play randos we can play but that means
we're just gonna get so killed is anyone
in the chat on battlefield hardline
search everywhere but especially
upstairs because that's probably where
they are you know make sure you search
everywhere yes we play Dragon Age with
Freddie Prinze jr. voice Oh Aaron bull
get him yeah you just go slow yeah I'm
careful yeah
they can't shoot through this
bulletproof glass oh I have hardline but
it's on my atari 2600 well played
Squasher fair enough mercs coffee I go
back hey there big is there gonna be a
clueless gamer for Counter Strike global
Offensive very that's a very hard game
to play and Konan really is extremely
bad yeah well you're terrible code is
extremely bad so it would it would be
rough
I'll John 201 Conan winning it whenever
he can he comes in because basically we
start rehearsal at 1:30 so which is why
we end our stream at 1:30 so he comes in
whenever he can
[Music]
oh we should you ice and Schmidt you're
right we should do a thing up later
about last that'd be awesome
light him up get some cover manga find
some cover
yeah hashtag Conan extremely bad he is a
lot of times we like for instance we
just did the witcher 3 and we had to
play for like three hours because it was
what we cut out of the clues gamers is
basically me just going like all right
go to the left no no the other left
other way don't you use the other stick
use the other stick it's the other stick
all right now hit the button like and
when you cut all that down it ends up
being about 12 minutes after you cut all
that down
alright we're getting out of this lobby
yeah aren't you answer some questions
the chat I'm gonna Silas Lobby I'm gonna
be my full concentration to shoot
everybody in the dick here we go hashtag
Weiner warrior you know what I'm gonna
see what's up
we have
that's right come on run on up fellas
come on up here are you looking forward
to Star Wars Battlefront I'm looking
forward to anything so it looks awesome
Oh made you see that shot that got so
hard in the dick he flew back are did
you have a nickname for bleh that you
say when he isn't around nothing he can
say on the street yeah well looking at
me shoot like it'll blow apart the thing
all right day whoa what is your favorite
oh I didn't see it it went away flavor
of gummy bear Oh bread is what cherry or
strawberry have you be eating no I
haven't high school they taste like
lemon drops it is oh that's weird lemon
that's where the flavor of lemon drops
were invented exactly
mine was peanut butter belly Oh kids can
be so cruel
wow there's a lot of bad guys here
Kings are flavored ice cream
oh my god some casual just dodging my
shotgun player he's like probably
cookies-and-cream
what I like to do honestly every ice
cream place I go do I asked the person
working with their favorite and I get
back I know I know somebody who gets
strawberry at every single ice cream
place why and we so he can compare ice
cream that's there we go
love to finish I've won right though is
that it bread the old junk yeah get in
the truck get in the truck that's a huge
truck this thing yeah there's no way
this thing is like you want to drive all
right right trigger drives yeah the guy
could dodge it right chocka gotta judge
a shotgun but he's like I can't shoot
you but he's like what are you doing I'm
trying go gotta go wait trigger is
exactly driving with Artie in real life
dear Jaco 37 what's our fate what's my
favorite pet I'll tell you I want them
to miniaturize an elephant okay I've
talked about this before I'll talk about
it you see Jurassic world I haven't seen
Jurassic world yet I love dinosaurs but
do they have tiny elephants they have
tiny dinosaurs oh that's great but I
want to any elephants man how cute would
that be ABI oh yeah I know super and ice
cream waffle darts I also know uh blue
moon which is also a great idea
yes Superman favorite ice cream can I
shoot this thing that's right he's
learning how to drive for the second
time you're doing good man I figure out
how to drink you chasing chase that
helicopter okay
followed the chopper just a normal day
on the 405 yeah hey fish pan what's up
road rage marca fish back can you work
for us I don't know what are your skills
yeah what do you have to give us give us
a rundown of your resume then I tried
bubble tea I try not to drink things
with bubble in the name my thoughts on
ant-man are I didn't like it you said
then I saw no no I didn't I do I wasn't
in for it and then I saw the trailer now
I'm totally it looks great really yeah
cuz I didn't understand like I love the
tone that they set for me at I tae Jun
mo statistic game of the year I'm really
looking forward to fallout 4 I didn't
know looking forward to well done really
looking forward to the new Halo is
amazing sorrows battlefront looks great
what else am I looking forward to I just
downloaded hearthstone
where's that it's a it's a game you can
play like on your phone it's like a card
game like Magic the Gathering
oh I just downloaded a game on my phone
first game ever done what is it nice ah
very excited for how bad is coated as a
boss he's a badass as a boss takes about
one right now playing hard lines oh yeah
look at all the phone cables I have
arkham knight looks very cool
get used to it no but seriously which
page I think it's like page 37 yeah
there's let me check the index what page
[ __ ] us okay great great perfect all
right let's try to play some multiplayer
it might not work but we're gonna give
it a shot
we're gonna give it a shot any holes in
our department I can think of a humor
right here fish pin I'm like Georgia
slaves got their various skills well we
already have a Jordan shlonsky so we
don't need another one
we can only have one murderer he's not
alleged murderer on our staff at all
times
whoa watch it Tusker thievery all right
let's do it
let's try it we're gonna try to do some
multiplayer here
I love it what is that what is it what
are you doing it's not a party
oh it's pinball it's like a pinball
pinball thing maybe those eyebrows this
clown eyebrows what our client I browse
what do you think about Ice Cube I think
ice cubes them in wait does he host
sing-off I mean not sing off the
lip-sync ice cubes great ice cube is I
went to Arizona State University a lot
of people don't know that about ice cube
because I like hip-hop and I enjoy ice
cubes whole catalogue pinball baby or
Klein I browse either or fair enough I
prefer clown eyebrows yeah awesome so
I'm so happy they're making it Deadpool
is Flair did you see they're also doing
gambit oh really with Channing Tatum
okay okay I guess it didn't Taylor
Kitsch already played Taylor Kitsch
maybe you know it looks great the new
true detective who sought Game of
Thrones last night by that not me it's
awesome
yes boil it for a sec spoil it for Jack
god I haven't seen any of it a certain
point in which I get to date that
Detective yeah this guy this guy he's my
boss I don't want to date him that's
right spoil it for RJ now come on no
spoilers I'm sorry chef anyway
Beth you're gonna have to tell me the
questions look at this lighting in this
game by the way they should turn on the
overheads because I think you they could
see their paperwork better it looks like
why are all the lights shut off in this
office this is a horrible I mean I know
it's dramatic but like yeah I really
gotta get someone to change these bulbs
exactly exactly the rest gets kind of
weird what do you think about this I'm
thinking about doing my hair like this
I don't watch house of cards so really
yeah spoil it spoil house of cards for
me because I don't watch it I don't care
whoa she's real sweaty sweaty we are
gross Jesus I was just like fishing what
are we doing yeah fire this baby up and
go this is the part of the story that we
should listen really I don't think so
these fans most of my life is a blur
this came in fish man this game is
fantastic yes EGS PNG does have a
trucker mouth
I'd say worse what's worse than a
trucker mouth oh let's go
find the drugs and Christian Bale's
brother drug bail yeah just good lord
tour guide shut up oh my god shut up we
don't care we don't care
yeah built sweat line danger zone yes
this looks like an upset yeah this is
like duck dynasty yeah I can't why is
she talking there's a giant fan shut up
this is beautiful look at this sunset
guys yeah it's got in the West Nile
what's worse than a trucker's mouth
really I don't know
sailors sailors mouth your mom's mouth
Bebe's nuts 100 I'm sorry we'll turn on
the the subtitles but I honestly don't
care what she's saying so I don't really
want to turn them on they grew another
guess we're just stranded I think I want
to take the rest of the game you take a
left take a left I think you want to
like take a left seat on the mat I think
yeah
there we go there we go this is it let's
say right there that's right there
that's over there tagged it tagged it to
see where workers we're tagging to see
where gose they're gonna pick it up so
now we got to go somewhere else a slip
21 will you play fallout 4 I hope so I'd
love to play fallout 4 I will be playing
it in my real life
take knocks I literally can't play games
without subtitles
Oh Gator to the right to the right are
you guys playing naked and afraid that's
my fish man I'm serious that you guys
need a game tester what do you think I
do no yes yes you do
we need a game taster yeah what about
that lit up delicious that's right
that's the included pit boy waffle ah
that's only for the special edition I
like it that's awesome
I think if you guys didn't see in the
pathetic thing last night they said that
they're gonna have them we're gonna make
a physical pip-boy which if you played
the game is a giant SmartWatch basically
you can put your phone in and actually
use the second screen experience it's a
very smart it's gonna be fun to play
witcher 3 mark out yes play with your
three it's awesome great professionally
personally I've known him professionally
since 2001 personally does anyone really
know killing it
I love it I'm seeing a lot of five
nights at freddys we always see that I'm
gonna have to check that out
we should we will yes I've been working
out yes you're strapping your phone to
your arm Squasher that's true tag the
final bail guys maybe we should just go
home yeah that's it she has to think all
right we'll try why try why no you don't
have the tagging thing oh you know what
wait wait to press this to the left
there we go Conan doesn't wear it oh
that you know what that's a Taser
sorry he's described his own smell as
nervous cheese there you go this kind of
smell like I don't know I don't smell
yeah I mean he's a robot so he kind of
smells like plastic and burnt wiring hey
[Music]
guys here we go
heyy Bo wad what's going on we love this
temple also tag it my friend Dave guys
is it nice to be over right now really
that's right tase the drugs we tried
tasting the drugs didn't work what are
we smell like I don't know I'd smelled
like farts and sadness what are you
smell like I smell like actually you
kind of smell like bubble gum slight
detergent I just been rolling around a
wood pile I've experiment it's like a
wood piling no you don't smell like
chlorine
would like a woodpile like bad I've also
had allergies for the past three days so
bad what are good good what it's a good
smell outdoors yeah no I don't think
it's a bad smell I'm gonna swim over
this yeah now I hope you have to fight a
gator Oh that'd be cool oh wait here we
go oh my god yeah maybe you should just
shoot it with your tagging gun next
don't make me get the alligator Preston
waters why why approach the rope made a
good point stabbing the Gator in the
mouth kills it yeah we just be angry
yeah shoot it yeah I'd like to give it a
try how do I do that tell us how can you
X X
oh my god yeah she shot Gator in the
deep probably like here right I don't
know where it says you can how about at
the shiny area
Batman hashtag Batman style no no you're
fine you're fine just go to the rope
you're fine okay yeah baby get up there
guys we're just joining us we're playing
battlefield hardline we ask people to if
you can jump online if you have an xbox
one a battlefield hardline and we're
going to play against you in a few
minutes here and also in the next half
hour we're gonna be showing a sneak
preview of tonight's newest clueless
gamer featuring halo 5 guardians as well
as I don't know if I should even bring
this up but the cast of Silicon Valley
that's right it's pretty exciting and
make sure to watch tonight at 11 o'clock
on TBS for that segment it'll also be
online tomorrow to koco.com slash
clueless gamer yeah dude
walk over to the other thing they're
good wait King Hawks love blood-borne
super fun game really hard it makes me
angry makes me yeah yeah there you go
whoa use that zipline brah yeah ouch be
so you see how they're looking at you at
the white on the map no see on the map
the color yeah I was noticing last week
that Thomas Middleditch does a lot of
twitch like himself yeah he's the man
yes I talked to I talked to Thomas about
coming on our stream so hopefully he'll
be he'll come on at some point that
works so far away it looks super
realistic we just fought a thing I guess
what if I did this year's e3 special
instead of Conan that would be great
let's talk to cut it about it you're
burning up
you're burning up you're burnin rollin
I'm stop thinking write it up you're
dead dead man he's gonna help me where
is she she gave me some life anyone else
yeah anyone else that's a shock
we just gonna look at them all day
[ __ ] get in there to see them there
and there's nobody on the map there's a
guy right there I just saw him
[Laughter]
Jesus clear very clear after I fired a
thousand bullets and caught on fire
wait how do I steal this unexpected
Misha wood coated stick replacement this
guy's a clueless gamer look at all the
coke everywhere need a little pick-me-up
just rvdude RB what's RB mean whole day
a nice whole day to analyze not just
snow in his pocket go to the other thing
on the map go into the cabin go to the
cabin
go into the cabin there we go
nice to the right yes
nice stuff this is people watch King
Hawks
sorry yep can we grill there's beer
please all right I've not seen Jurassic
world Lothar view are you taking a
selfie all right great job get back in
the boat whoa boat time best to get them
leads I think should we try I think we
should try to do a multiplayer yeah I do
love this got the language in this show
it's probably an HBO show here's a lot
of dinosaurs in Jurassic world I'm very
I'm very excited I can't wait to watch
it for you duh-duh that's that that's
that theme is unbelievable all right my
ringtone no friends playing in no
servers marked his favorite fantastic
just gonna pop out here two friends see
if there's any friends who added us here
we go oh that's right here we go all
right all right kids and you guys are
some friends
RJ tell us give us a quick review while
we're waiting yeah Jurassic world I
don't want to spoil anything well I'll
tell you this aren't you an adult can
see why it's good the reason
good to me is because it pushes all the
nostalgia buttons like what well that's
kind of the fun you it there's tons of
references to the first movie which is
really fun okay and there's a lot of
dinosaurs and Chris Pratt is the man
great what do you think about Chris
Pratt being Indiana Jones potentially
love it yeah it's good although I have
to say like one of the things like I
mean this might not be possible but I
like the fact like with Star Wars a
little bit with Indiana Jones that I
wasn't well I guess Harry shapour was a
huge star by the time he did
Indiana Jones right yeah so it's like
it's hard to kind of yeah that true I
could see that I mean why not it would
be Jurassic world I mean it's the same
franchise it makes sense to me that it
would be yeah so still now yeah before
it's cool all right here we go
multiplayer we got some people it says
no friends playing now I just oh keep an
eye out for Jimmy Buffett in Jurassic
world what yeah how do we do this new
squad or wait do I want new squad with
friends available start a party boy do I
want new squad what do I want usually
their friends start a party somebody
says how do I do that
how do we start for you guys anyone know
a quick match this is what are you folks
who's Jimmy Buffett
the lego games are great kept bone
they're fantastic squad join customized
by reddit servers anyone know what to do
here this would help us new squad it is
so now I'm the leader
oh I see this is how we did last time
right I can invite people yeah better in
the menus yep yep yep all right I'm
looking for people who are playing oh
there's tons of people yeah yeah we got
a banana guy
people were brave victorious PAP you're
in Wells's there we might only play with
one other person all these people are
offline nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope
Oh one hour ago still there Gami num
nums I see should we try inside I'm sure
if you're on you're just gonna play with
us it's gonna be fine go back there with
someone someone said we missed someone
Toscanini who was it where no there's a
delay yeah we're Lance freakin believe
Phil sick and Phil Miller
late towards the start there was someone
that's in I Neal I got somebody that I'm
gonna go back don't worry I just want to
hit all if you guys are on battlefield
hardline now is the time if you want to
play with us Duke Ironsides is on your
car inside Yujin
I'll start the beginning no that's
battlefield for watching twitch III I
like it
who next time maybe we'll do Call of
Duty advanced warfare that's pretty fun
no I think we got all the folks were
playing with today
that's alright alright hold a good time
let's see anyone else doo doo doo doo
doo doo what happened to the PC that you
ordered talked about several weeks ago
it's at my house
Jason O'Malley's gonna come over help me
set up twitch it's gonna be fantastic
whoo this week right Oh Mouse whoo
we'll see we'll see but yes we don't
have advanced warfare here do it that's
good enough
only one person all right let's do it
all right de Tori's b.a.p you're gonna
play with us so let's do it quick match
squad is that we want I knew we should
be against each other no all right here
we go we're doing it notorious b.a.p
we're the only person playing with us
let's do it
dr. hex opposed is just my name Erin
Blair on twitch and that'll be you know
I'm gonna I'll go and we're gonna sing
uh stream for the first time next
weekend this coming weekend it's
official right
today it's gonna happen this week it'll
be the first time oh actually very
exciting on Saturday is the year
anniversary of your working out so all
Saturday it's gonna be a garbage crawl
I'm gonna eat garbage the entire day
because I am the bathroom
that's right let's start with Lake oh
this is gonna be a big chicken and
waffles yeah chicken while this guy
seriously doesn't do cheats chicken
waffles in the morning we start on
Friday we'll get pizza oh that's a good
idea
uh come on what game will you stream
bleh they're asking oh I don't know yeah
what game what game should I stream this
weekend guys let me know tell me what
tell me what game you guys want me to
stream I'll stream it I'd prefer not a
PC game my first time out the PCs gonna
be streaming things this is a Monday
mailer question do you always use Xbox
or never change it up we change it up
all the time actually
okay what happened we were but it said
we lost the thing who is the guy
notorious b.a.p was on here Super Mario
64 Toscanini I like your smile ooh I
like it
where did theis b.a.p go that's the only
game I could be you I bet you could oh
that's not a bad idea
that's a good guys fun we know this is
awful
this is awful Aaron doesn't drink during
his downtime he plays video games that's
true it's very true very true
I don't do anything but a lot of weeping
also mm-hmm crying of crying towards
b.a.p you're in let's do it
come on give it to me 205
good turn server there we go all right
notorious PAP let's get it done you get
to play the RJ first yeah warming up
with me if I beat you you sucked no
we're not playing against somebody your
squad don't you listen to Drake I've
never seen a two persons oh but they're
gonna add other people there we go
very exciting very exciting here we go
so just hit a don't deploy you're on the
police side okay kill all the bad guys
where are you notorious where's the
tories PAP where is he you know one of
the cars or something let's do this to
it go go go
icicles now if the guy at the guys are
if if you can see their name above you
there they're on your team
hashtag squad goals here we go Simon
cello Simon CIBC dose I'm Michelle I've
been listening to a lot of Drake lately
oh really like the young bad you you
want to take over that truck do we know
do you have possession that truck or no
I'm getting it right now this is how you
do it but are you sure that a bad guy
isn't a beat whoa whoops
what happened sorry I think I've moved
you over to the other side oh Jesus I'm
just sorry
don't let me touch a thing anymore
somebody else is driving the car perfect
is that notorious I don't know charrisse
you driving
take the wheel bro this is chaos all
right we did wait oh yeah I don't
where's the tour it's in this truck
where's the tour you set the toys were
you that your squadmates are green oh
there's a bad guy coming up the side
really yeah dude
turn around side oh there he is right
there Oh God
oh you gotta get killed you're gonna I'm
love with the Coco so are we don't let
me touch your thing anymore
yeah sorry notorious worse oh man
imagine of multiplayer clues camera
Conan keeps killing his teammates yeah I
don't have to really imagine it go let's
go deploy deploy deploy control marked
vehicles no one was in the car with you
I know they were where's our boy yet
let's keep track of Team Coco record
yeah it's gonna be a lot of deaths on
our part we need to get in the car
wanna see car ID you don't want to get
in your cardio there you go that's
that's our boy
there is Dorian we're jumping it yay all
right let's go datoria let's go
you beat the way your head you gotta
well you got a dinosaur head that's cool
hella tight here we go notorious you run
funny - notorious you know what don't
make fun in Tory's our friend let's go
let's go let's go or we get into this
car oh yeah how do I get that car let's
do it
I hope he's a good driver Oh God
Oh we just captured this car boom
captured it let's kill somebody blow it
up I just do it here we go
yeah dude this is great I think it's
better that there's nobody to shoot cuz
that means we'd be in trouble Horace
you're like a dope right now man hell
yeah this is awesome
it's just a nice driving all right Oh
jumper not like that oh boy yeah but see
he's doing it right I guess this is
great I don't even have to kill anybody
I gotta see it was a good day didn't you
have to use my aku no oh whoops
easy Oh easy tutorial
whoa what's happening where's everyone
shoot again who are these people
how do I get out of this car all right
somebody else is driving is it notorious
no nope sorry two Taurus see we'll catch
you on the flip side whoa get it Jesus
Christ at the jump Who am I supposed to
be shooting at yeah exactly
I'm ready to go to kill somebody got a
lot of bullets whoa whoa whoa
damnit
Oh notorious find me let's do it do we
know what aureus looks like on the map
kind of wrap your head he's green he's
got a green he's green
he's the only other green guy you know
oh yeah back
yeah this is great tusks ooh I have
played evolve if all it makes me very
drive-by dick shot well makes me very
nervous all right well this is a very
nerve-wracking shield don't worry it's
already out oh yeah it was bad nope I
don't think so Red's back-rent Reds bad
I think yeah oh yeah here you go here
you go yeah
kill him you know what's it that jump oh
dude those are bad guys and they don't
have things that's a bad guy that's a
bad guy oh that's a bad guy kill that
guy kill that guy kill that guy just
shoot somebody hook maybe your legs were
crushed they were okay I want to start
more in the middle here oh you can pick
where to start yeah I think so I guess
yeah back oh wait we lost that aureus
thanks JD fridge how do we get out the
side of the window dude go go 0-3 yeah
we gotta kill this single player all
right I don't lean out the window like
that
maybe this thing that's a grenade sorry
it's all right though veteran shooting
in the car
he's gonna shoot let's just shoot
randomly just shooting let's just shoot
let's do it
oh Jesus oh oh now I'm out of the car
hey Team Coco hey hey go all the crime
oh there's victorious later notorious
dude good could see oh there we go I'm
gonna kill this guy
I think I kind of hit a hit with a few
press the right stick wrong rights right
joystick get you out of them gets you
bleep lets you lean out of the fed in
the car
Oh like push it down TerraCycle yeah
dude yeah
owners whoo roadkill I don't know
oh good oh good writing this yeah all
right you all right just start shooting
Network that was awful that was the
driver's fault uh deploy me I'm a boy
notorious PAP wiener warrior roadkill
all right a Taurus I got I got you where
we going wiener warrior lead the way bro
lead the way let's do this Taurus
there's no triangle so they're lying
boys I think maybe you can maybe where's
the tories going no Horace where you
going bro the reason why you can't see
anyone online is because Xbox Live is
having problems oh thank you
Duke thanks dude that sucks really fun
master for land forces ha
so you're not any better at this I never
said I was
I never said I've got here all day never
sighs they're entertaining to buy this
game this is a really fun game I would
say yeah it's gorgeous the single player
is really fun I like how it's set up
like a TV show which is really great
yeah that was good yeah it's pretty fun
next week hey dude nice yeah
Zach the pony yeah there's a lot of
people watching the twitchy three stuff
and right well stick to stick with our
boy notorious where is it I don't know
is he on us we left it behind you left
him behind no he's shooting other people
you're trying to get those marked
vehicles so go to one of the letters
whoo
Oh God Oh God oh geez Oh God Oh God hold
on hold on everybody
how do i back up Oh God anyone know how
to back up I'm left trigger left trigger
left trigger that's pretty sweet
well done well done
where's my boy at I'm a boy just died
right there I'm going to the Chop give
me the chopper can you ride a helicopter
- there we go
yeah yeah fly this thing I'd rather
shoot Oh God I I just select sieving
it's selected when you're uh it's not
always in the air watching our jet
figure out controls is highly
entertaining yeah sorry sorry everyone
yeah there you go deploy deploy oh yes
they are the big thing on kill him -
kill him kill him kill him get out get
out get out get out hit ax hit acts
enacted X Y X nice o1 tried you got a
Dipper
deploy your parachute hold on I want it
on it hook up with our boy my boy just
got killed
oh okay
quick is dead ever by the way we're like
we we've got oh nine yeah that was
awesome
holy crap whoa oh that's great you blew
up that car that was awesome where's
this guy guys why are we getting out cut
it out x2 get out x2 get out go away
dude
is is our boy driving so nope this guy
another guy this guy on five o'clock
shadow
yeah you're right dig a helicopter
Raymond
oh we killed one person I said oh there
we go nice thanks Luther thank you
Lothar I love it let's deploy let's
deploy get in there I don't want to do
all the way don't make me deploy the way
over there oh don't make me deploy away
over there all right let's do this I
spanked my kelps as we died style it's
the only way I know how to live I live
like I died that baby oops
whoops okay I spanked my cups whoops
well no I'm stupid I just said that's
the way I live baby and then I jumped
out of the car like an idiot whoa
actually I'm glad I'm not in that car
because I would have been dead like this
is good this is building up a lot of
good stamina
he's good oh Jesus God that's horrifying
do not expect Thank You gotta get oh my
god alright hello howdy hey yeah it's
just right here yep that's all it is
here we go yeah buddy welcome Tony yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah
sorry just feel Jesus right all right
say hi to everybody in the chat
hey everyone in the chat Conan O'Brien
here with a big scoop big story to share
with all of you I'm not even looking at
your negative comments yeah sure a lot
of like I just creamed somebody yeah
yeah listen gang gather round get close
gather round get close to your computers
cuz this is important I have an
announcement to make
okay on tonight's show I am going I have
challenged the cast of Silicon Valley
and I am going to play them in a major
competition exclusively on the halo 5
Guardians game that's right Conan
O'Brien and Andy Richter and what's your
name again Aaron not important he'll be
replaced tomorrow where it's it's us
against the Silicon Valley cast playing
the new halo 5 Guardians game which
isn't even out yet and it's a fight to
the death and it's gonna be really cool
it's gonna air on tonight's show you've
got to watch it's gonna be a lot of fun
that's right shut up yes we're gonna
sneak preview we have a hold on I get to
say that
I have a sneak preview and I'm gonna
show it to you right now so yeah get all
your friends on the phone does anyone
use a phone anymore
in my day we had a phone it had a crank
on it anyway get the word out here's an
exclusive sneak peek at my challenge
against the Silicon Valley cast in a
game of Halo 5 Guardians and go what do
you want where we don't kill each other
we just walk up to each other and talk
sorry Thomas I'm good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I hope you enjoyed that now I was
assured by my team that there were no
negative comments but my I drifted over
during the clip and I saw that someone
out there said Conan's jacket looks like
he stole it from an 8th grade science
teacher well maybe I did that's not fair
I bought it from a seventh grade science
teacher so you're wrong what's wrong
with the Internet
[Music]
anyway you got me good
but that's not the point we're gonna
accentuate the positive eliminate the
negative and it's tonight's show on
tonight's show sorry all exclusive stuff
people have never seen before it's very
extend its exclusive you've never seen
it before are you on that what are you
doing yeah I just I was talking to these
people for the last hour they're so thin
they're so crazy now just curtsy I can
here's the great thing and this is my
message to you when if you work hard in
life you can some day have people work
for you and you're allowed to hit them
and they can't do anything
we have no HR department here they can
do nothing I can hit anybody I want but
they can also hit me Sona get in and hit
me really quickly it's my assistant Sona
Sona sit here and just ow all right okay
now really hit me this hard as you
usually do oh yeah okay my god all right
and then I cuz I'm not allowed to hit
her so it's complicated all right watch
it you can make fun of it
alright that'll do it for today's Monday
relay that you've enjoyed us make sure
to watch tonight where we play the cast
of Silicon Valley at halo 5 guardians
thank you guys for joining us see you
tonight
and see you next Monday